right now Taylor Swift fans are lined up
around Allegiant Stadium waiting to get
Swifty swag ahead of the pop star's
upcoming shows she's bringing her eras
tour to Las Vegas tomorrow night at 6 30
and again on Saturday so let's go out
there live look at that line right now
the merch bus parked outside of Legion
today some fans showed up as early as
six this morning to snag the goodies
before the big concert scene they just
couldn't resist getting to the venue
early because there were some reports
from her Glendale opening that suggested
that merch might be hard to come by at
the Las Vegas show
we came early because we knew that like
it's Taylor Swift we know what happened
down in Glendale like so it was like we
have to make sure we're here because I
need the merch like we need the merch
anything for Taylor
anything for Taylor you heard it right
here you get your hands on Taylor Swift
swag today until seven the bus is parked
in Lot B good luck